[موسيقى]
الاضرابات تشل اسرائيل ونتنياهو يعلق خطط
التعديلات بقع على ملابس زعيم كوريا
الشماليه قد تؤدي بحريصه الى الاعدام
عواصف مطريه تعطل مدارس العراق هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في وقت لا يزال فيه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يواجه ضغوطا
متزايده سواء من المعارضه او من حلفائه في
الحكومه بشانه التعديلات القضائيه التي
يسعى لتمريرها في الكنيست ضغط اكبر في
الشارع وقف بوجه نتنياهو من خلال موجه
اضرابات شلت الاقتصاد والحركه الجويه
والبحريه في اسرائيل فضلا عن مظاهرات
حاشده تزايد زخمها بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع
يوف ماذا فعلت نياهو الى تعليق التعديلات
القضائيه والدعوه الى تجنب
الاعدام او الاشغال الشاقه هي عقوبه تنتظر
مساعد الزعيم الكوري الشماليه على خلفيه
ظهور كيم جونغ اون في ستره متسخه ببقع
بيضاء خلال حضوره اطلاقا صاروخ باليستين
المساعد يواجه تهمه عدم حمايه كرامه
الزعيم المتمثله في مظهره العام امام شعبه
فيما قال مراقبون ان المسؤولين في كوريا
قد يواجهون كسرا في رتبهم او الاشغال
الشاقه ولا يمكن استبعاد عقوبه الاعدام
اذا اغضبوا الزعيم
[موسيقى]
في العراق ادت عاصفه مطريه الى اغراق
العديد من الاحياء والشوارع في مدن وسط
وجنوب البلاد الامر الذي يكون السلطات الى
تعطيل الدوام الحكومي اليوم وفقا لتوجيهات
من مجلس الوزراء وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تناقلت صورا وفيديوهات لشوارع مليئه
وغارقه بمياه الامطار التي تسببت بوقوع
اضرار ماديه ومن المتوقع ان تستمر الامطار
الى يوم غد وفقا لهيئه الارصاد العراقيه
والى اخبار الفن والفنانين حيث قضت
المحكمه الاقتصاديه في مصر بالزام الفنانه
شيرين عبد الوهاب بدفع غرامه بخمسه ملايين
جنيه لصالح شركه روتانا لعدم التزامها
ببنود العقد المبرم بينهما الطرفان تنازعا
حول بعض البنود التي تم ابرامها بين
الطرفين حيث طلبت الشركه من الفنانه دفع
عشره ملايين جنيه بينما اكدت شيرين انها
لم تخل او تخل ببنود العقد وانها على
استعداد تام لتسليم البومها المنصوص عليه
في الاتفاق
في عمليه قرصنه معلومات واسعه النطاق سرق
نحو ثمانيه ملايين رقم رخصه لرخص قياده
استراليه ونيوزيلنديه بحسب ما اعلنت
الشركه الرقميه المسؤوله عن البيانات
الشركه كشفت ايضا عن سرقه ارقام لنحو
53,000 جواز سفر بالاضافه الى كشوف
الحسابات الماليه الشهريه لنحو 100000
عميق مؤكده انها تعمل على اصلاح الثغرات
التي ادت الى ذلك الاختراق في ماده
العمليه ايرين انخفاض اسهمها بنسبه تصل
الى 2.5
[موسيقى]